first of all you can't tell me not to do
something I'm too stubborn it's clear
cher has no filter the iconic singer
proved just that when playing a game of
five-second rule on The Ellen DeGeneres
Show
I came three celebrities you'd want to
do a duet with Oh Adele pink and not
Madonna
[Applause]
well.alright ms- she yeah she yeah
that's not he said when you'd want to
it's not who you wouldn't want to
license I took a little lucky you did
okay but you got two of them of course
share throwing shade at Madonna is
nothing new the pop diva has a long
history of getting candid about how she
really feels about match back in the
early nineties shared did not hold back
in interviews with Steve commit Co Terry
Wogan and des O'Connor it's not like you
go around saying this is how I feel I'm
in but someone said to me what do you
think about it I said well I think she's
unbelievably creative
I mean I'm amazed at the amount because
in my day I was pretty good at doing the
same thing that she's doing but she does
it so much better but I mean she's
unbelievably creative because she's not
unbelievably talented she's not
beautiful but she's kind of she's rude
she's mean I don't like that and I
remember having her over in my house a
couple of times because Shawn and I were
friends and she just was
so rude to everybody it seems to me that
she's got so much that she doesn't have
to act the way that she acts like a
spoiled brat all the time it seems to me
when you reach the kind of a claim that
she's reached and can do whatever you
want to do you should be a little bit
more magnanimous and a little bit less
of she's a major major star and she's
not really a great great singer she's
not really a great great actress but
she's a man but she's one of the biggest
stars in the world so that's a special
art to be able to turn whatever you have
into it's like spinning straw into gold
[Music]